so
yeah i did i did another i did a load of
cocaine to australia
the biggest ever in the history of
australia i got caught with 400 million
dollars worth down there
tell me talk to me tell me about this
trip from
from the caribbean where they loaded up
your ship
to australia what was that like
well that was that was interesting i um
i left home louisiana i never never run
the ship before and i mean it was
a learning curve for me and somebody
left the
water on down in one of the bathrooms we
only had 600 gallons of fresh water
because we'd
change it all to fuel so we ran out of
water before we got to key west so i had
to go into key west and get water
and then i took off and went across the
tongue of the ocean through the bahamas
and i went to um senegal what's the
islands off of the
anyhow some island 600 miles off of
senegal
and uh i can't think of the name of them
right now
meaning i stayed there a week the
columbians told me they'd load me there
like uh barbados no no this is a this is
uh
what canary you know south of the canary
is about a thousand miles
i can't think of it i know it's good as
my own name i know that preya is the
name of the town
oh it's anyhow senegal okay and uh
so i stayed there and then the
colombians said no come back towards
colombia a thousand miles
now what because i just got enough money
just the
fuel just barely to make it to australia
so i have to go back a thousand miles
and then they're not there and i have to
go three or four days
cruising around up and down all over the
radar of the other satellites
and finally they show up and throw the
stuff on and uh
then i go down and i go follow the
center of the atlantic ocean down
because the current goes
counterclockwise in the southern ocean
clockwise in the northern oceans
and i went far south of cape town and
went down
went down about 50 degrees in the great
southern ocean
near antarctica and i came with it and
uh i woke up one morning and the
waves was i fished in alaska remember
yeah these waves was just
indescribably tall it wasn't rough but
they were just
mountains giant swells just swells and
it was sharp
i mean almost straight up and down and
the boat would come
and it would just come up and it would
stop and go and then the propellers
would come out of the water and they'd
be
surf down it and then surf down it in
the nose would stick in the ground
in the water they'd come back over well
i was real uncomfortable so i was
supposed to go under towards melbourne
so i
i got out of it and i turned north north
to get out of that
sharp latitude and i went unloaded uh
i went unloaded up about the middle of
the west australian coast
in a real desert area and was arrested
there
but i um i have visions and two weeks
before i was arrested i had a
crystal clear vision of me being
arrested how it was
in my feelings i uh i was they was on my
back with the hands and putting the
handcuffs on me and i was in the sand
with the
down there and i was crying and i was
just laying poor poor poor mari
i knew our life was over together and
it happened exactly like i saw it in
that vision so i turned my ship from
it went 500 miles from where i want both
to go but the snitch was waiting on me
so
i didn't have any choice who was the
snitch and the guy named eduardo the uh
the owner's brother friend and he had
been working with them from
day one so they knew all we were coming
from before we left
so your vision of this all this
happening and everything falling apart
came came to fruition yes
so what happened after they arrested you
oh they put us in a
bulletproof vans one of those things
like armored trucks and took us to
prison
wow and how many and you ended up
obviously so you didn't escape that
prison right you stayed in the water no
i didn't i
i could have one time and mari wouldn't
send the little money needed to
have some help tomorrow was passed at
you she ain't going to help me get out
were you were you guys in communication
at all did you guys communicate
every day australia prisons is so much
nicer than american prisons
really yeah oh they give you a long time
it's hard
but they treat you good the food's good
the officers seem to go to school to
have a little more
intelligence than just the scumbags that
they have
the officers are way different oh yeah i
feel like i've always i've always
thought
with all the people that i've talked to
that have been in and out of prison
especially on this podcast
is that the people that end up in the
united states that end up being prison
guards
are like the people who couldn't even
make it as cops they couldn't make it as
security guards they are the lowest lie
scum on the face of the earth and it
seems like
that the people that are the security
guards or prison guards
in this country they're they're not
people that are there because that's
what they wanted to be it's because they
failed at something else and they just
they got a job and they got a badge and
they got authority and they
just strut right you woke up going on
you get talked to ugly too
they kill people in there they hurt you
and the prison guards in australia was
it like they were they were paid better
they were educated more they actually
they
all of that was there like more of like
a a sense of like a mission to get
something done there
like we gotta oh it wasn't good but it
was just not
it wasn't such hatred as these fools
here have for you it just didn't really
ring for it oh you had some nasty ones
once in a while
right they'd be black one out of 20 or
30 might be nasty
okay but here you get every other one
that's nasty
right good 50 of them there's some nice
ones here too
but it's rare so how many years did you
stay in that president australia
18 years 18 years and it was the
most maximum security prison that there
is in that country
the most most secure prison in the
southern hemisphere the most secure
prison in the southern hemisphere which
no one has yet wow
and what was your experience like there
for 18 years
when i first went in i'd been in a week
or two and when they got my paperwork
that i
escaped from five different prisons they
came and arrested me right where i was
having supper
and they took me to to that prison i was
in the hakia prison they took me to
uh kazarina prison and they put me in a
shoe
and i was in there for over a year and
uh
and that's the shoe is basically just an
isolated box just by yourself
well there was five of us in this okay
and it was uh
it had room for 12 prisoners in there
and they had uh it was like kind of like
the silence of the lambs
that was a big cage and they had six
guards on the other side looking at you
through a one-way mirror
and they come in the morning with all of
them had uh big clubs
and they opened the door and they
brought food in we cooked it ourselves
and then they come in at six o'clock and
locked our doors and that was it that's
all we had in them
you had a little you could talk to them
through a through a speaker
and that was all it wasn't bad but it
was just like
how long am i going to be in here and
that's when i had the uh
i wondered okay i've got 25 years in
america and i've escaped from the german
prison i've done this
got life here i might never see my
children or my grandchildren
they might ever know me i believe i'll
write about
when i my grandma bought me the little
horse and they had a computer room in
there
you so you were you were there for life
you thought you were there for life
i was hoping i'd get out i certainly
behaved myself i had to go 18 years
before i
could ask for parole so uh
um i'd write it down okay i when i got
the mexican pinto i'm gonna write that
story tomorrow
so they had the little computer room
there and uh i didn't know how to
turn the thing on and it had a thing
called a
paint brush it didn't have a program on
it so i could type so i could type one
line
and then the next day i think about when
my daddy was robbed in chattanooga and
i'll write that little story
and then i got where i'd write two or
three of them a day and in the end of
about three or four months
i had over a million words written in
one line
wow so when i got out of the shoe they
gave it to me on on disk
and i went and uh got out and they they
let me buy a computer they let p let you
buy a computer oh really yeah
they weren't hooked up to anything but
you could do all the
you could put a lot of programs on it
like encyclopedias and like a laptop or
something
no it was a full-on computer and where
did you keep it in your in your cell
yeah really had a cell with a door and a
lock to it and
yeah a little while it's pretty nice
they know why about it now compared to
america it's quite no internet though no
okay nothing like that but you had
telephones and it wasn't expensive i
call mario every day for 20 minutes
so anyway i took that thing out and it
took me two years to straighten out what
all i had written saw what
it was all different colors where i'd
misspelled engine i just put what my
thoughts
so you went through and edited it and
revised it because i had to write it
really because
i was just writing my thoughts as fast
as i could just put them so that's how i
did it
so i took it out and i got
a took two-thirds of it out
so there's only 520 pages they'd have
been 1500 pages if i'd put it all in
there
wow
you